ups and downs.
TODD: A BIZARRE LOCKDOWN AT A
WYOMING HIGH SCHOOL WITH A
16-YEAR-OLD GETTING ARRESTED IN
HANDCUFFS.
THAT STUDENT AND ANDREW SMITH
ARE WITH US NOW.
DESCRIBE WHAT HAPPENED.
>> I’VE BEEN PROTESTING THE
MASK THING.
>>
>> A CONTINUED DISOBEDIENCE FOR
NOT COMPLIANCE WITH MASK
MANDATES AND DURING THE FIRST
HOUR I WENT TO OFFICE AND WITH
THEM ON LUNCHROOM BEFORE I WAS
SUSPENDED AND GAVE ME A SECOND
CITATION FOR TRESPASSING AFTER
MY SUSPENSION IT PROCEEDED TO
ARREST ME AFTER AN HOUR AND A
HALF.
ASKING TO GO BACK TO CLASS.
>> THIS IS HAPPENING.
>> I WANT TO GO BACK TO CLASS
SO I CAN LEARN, NEVER THOUGHT
THEY WOULD ARREST ME.
IT SURPRISED ME.
TODD: HOW TOUGH IS IT TO SEE
YOUR DAUGHTER BEING TREATED
WORSE THAN ACTUAL CRIMINALS IN
THE COUNTRY ARE BEING TREATED
RIGHT NOW.
>> IT IS APPALLING.
WE APPROACH THIS FROM A
PERSPECTIVE OF CONSTITUTIONAL
LAW.
NOT ONLY DESIGNED, INDIVIDUAL
CITIZENS OF THIS STATE BUT ALSO
THE STATE OF WYOMING WILL STEP
IN AND ACT ON OUR BEHALF.
WE WERE APPALLED AFTER THE
WHOLE PROCESS THAT NOBODY WOULD
ACT ON GRACE’S BEHALF, CIVIL
LIBERTIES GUARANTEED IN WYOMING
SO IT HAS BEEN AMAZING TO
WITNESS FROM AN OUTSIDER’S
PERSPECTIVE AND TOOK IT THIS
FAR.
NOBODY THROUGH THE ENTIRE
ADMINISTRATION WHETHER IT BE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND
COUNTY SHERIFF, DIDN’T GO.
TO STEP IN ON HER BEHALF.
TODD: LET’S CONTINUE TO VIEW
THIS.
I TO KEEP ON THIS DAD BE.
WITH THE REACTION TO YOUR
DAUGHTER TAKING A STAND LIKE
THIS?
>> SHE IS A STRONG-WILLED
CHILD, SHE IS BRILLIANT AND
AMAZING SO MY REACTION TO THIS
PROCESS HAS BEEN SUPPORT AFTER
WE FIGURED OUT THE MASK POLICY
WAS UNLAWFUL.
BURSTING WITH PRIDE, AND
STANDING UP FOR HERSELF.
TODD: THERE WAS A BRIEF
LOCKDOWN, STUDENT DISCIPLINARY
DISTURBANCE, GOES ON TO HAVE A
FEW MORE DETAILS, THE LOCKDOWN
WAS ISSUED TO PREVENT FURTHER
INTERRUPTIONS TO ACADEMIC
LEARNING.
WOULD YOU DO IT AGAIN.
>> NOT SAFE TO BE AT ALL,
THERE’S A THREAT OF SCHOOL
SHOOTING --
TODD: ALL OVER A MASK.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO THOSE
WHO FEEL THEIR RIGHTS ARE BEING
TRAMPLED ON IN THIS CONTEXT OR
JUST IN GENERAL.
>> EVERY RIGHT YOU FEEL IS
BEING INFRINGED UPON IS WORTH
FIGHTING FOR YOU.
A QUOTE OF BENJAMIN FRANKLIN
SAYING THOSE WHO SACRIFICE A
LITTLE BIT OF LIBERTY FOR A
LITTLE BIT OF SAFETY DESERVE
NEITHER LIBERTY NOR SAFETY.
TODD: WHAT ARE WE DOING?
AND WON’T WHERE A MASK.